hey everyone welcome to metaphysical
milkshake i'm rayne wilson and i'm
president aslan
reza
yeah uh how are you man you look a
little tired there yeah man try having
four kids during a pandemic okay
no no no no no that's that's not it have
you been sleeping okay
well
first of all no i have not and second of
all when i do get to sleep i i've been
having this like recurring nightmare
oh wow tell me well i log on as usual to
do our podcast
but instead of me
being your co-host
it's david cho
what do you think that means
reza that was one time
you were sick there was a pandemic going
on and we needed to record i know you
guys were just so good together like we
really we actually really were i feel
like we're very like i really have no
no place in this podcast anymore what do
you think this dream actually means reza
i how should i have no idea what dreams
mean i once dreamed that i looked in the
mirror and had the face of barbara bush
barbara bush is hot she's underrated
she was i was attracted to myself it was
true welcome to metaphysical milkshake
the show where we go deep we get weird
and we search for the meaning of life
along the way presented by cast media
and soul pancake
[Music]
so yeah this is a great question what in
the hell do dreams ever mean what are
dreams
so there's we've got folks um this was
so much fun to dig into this episode so
many incredible
facts about dreams uh
in fact here's a few we're gonna throw
some at you to kind of begin the
discussion
in an average sleep cycle of seven eight
hours you will experience five sleep
cycles and five dream episodes within
them so everyone is dreaming five times
a night five times a night
well okay here's the interesting thing
the first of the sleep cycle episodes
lasts about 10 to 15 minutes and then
you're the length of your dream
increases with each one of the sleep
cycles so that means that last sleep
cycle that that fifth one
your dream could be anywhere
up to 40 minutes long which which makes
sense right like that that's that last
dream that always it's always
yeah that last the richest dream that
you're having at like six in the morning
the longest most complicated dream and
it it literally is
yeah
and uh fun fact 95 of all dreams are
quickly forgotten i know i really 99 for
me yeah 99 actually here's a fun fact
did you know that obviously most people
dream in color but about 12 of people
claim that they can only dream in black
and white and
even more interesting
of that 12 percent
the majority were over the age of 55
and people think that the reason that is
because they grew up watching black and
white tv
amazing not cool
so all of the black and white dreamers
are
are dying off
eventually yes
and uh here's another fun fact about
dreams men and women dream differently
several studies men dream more about
weapons than women
and women dream more about clothing than
men men's dreams have more aggressive
content and physical activities well
oftentimes women's dreams come contain
more rejection and exclusion
as well as more conversation really than
physical activity women have longer
dreams
that feature more characters
and men dream about other men twice as
often as they do about women
while women tend to dream about both
sexes equally
you know i feel like you don't need to
be a dream scientist to have known that
one
you know what i mean like it just seems
men dream about weapons women dream
about friends really
yeah comedy routine
uh here's something here's another fun
fact about dreams i knew this i think
you knew this but a lot of people know
this you can control your dreams right
it's called lucid
dreaming but it's not some like
superpower right i mean some people are
better at it than other people but you
can actually
learn to control your dreams simply by
uh repeating a phrase i will remember my
dreams i will remember my dreams or by
like focusing on certain stimulus so we
all have the ability
to actually have lucid dreams
uh i've had many of those
i have a lot of lucid dreams where i'm
like and i love that sensation of like
oh i'm having a dream right now
you know what ask him a question you
know go to the giant talking tortoise in
your kitchen is eating a peanut butter
sandwich and yeah ask him you know what
tv show he likes or whatever and you're
able to kind of like
be in there your consciousness is riding
along and it's always a positive
experience it's kind of like oh this is
kind of it is always a positive
experience you're right
it doesn't happen to me too often but
every time it happens to me my first
thought is well [ __ ] this dream i'm
gonna go fly
like i'll be in the middle of a dream
and i'll realize i'm dreaming and i'll
be like i'm gonna stop this conversation
and jump out the window i'm gonna take
off just like superman yeah
i wonder too uh reza a little off topic
but um
if the the physics of our dreams you
know the fact that we
can fly somewhere that we
instantaneously appear somewhere that
people appear from out of the blue that
will jump time frames all of a sudden
we're three years old then we're 90
years old
if this has given people an idea of what
the afterlife might contain or some of
the the rules of physics and logic in
some kind of afterlife where it's beyond
time and space really um
and often dreams are so emotional and i
know that's something we're gonna get
into uh with our guest today but anyways
let's just see now this is a very this
is a great transition because
you know what we're talking about is all
these fun facts about dreams right
but the truth of the matter is that
as much as we've been studying you know
dreams for a century or more
we actually don't really understand them
you know we we have no idea why we dream
we still don't have any consensus about
why
we dream yeah there's a bunch of
theories out there but they all kind of
seem like [ __ ] to me they're so lame
these scientific theories of like
we need to sort our memories in the
correct data of silos in at night
that's right we are we are doing
categorization we're basically filing
uh in our i don't i don't believe it's
like accounting yeah so let's bring on
an expert all right this is this is one
we're just we're not gonna get this on
our own okay yeah and i read a little
bit of freud i love i read a little bit
of jung
but
we need a fresh perspective
uh over uh what our dreams actually mean
why we dream how to understand our
dreams and so that's our guest tonight
dr ian wallace he is a dream expert
uh ian wallace is a psychologist who
specializes in dreams and dreaming um
he's originator of the dream connection
process a way to have insights into your
dreams and have them make a healthy
difference in your life
he's the author of top 100 dreams the
dreams we all have and what they really
mean that is a bestseller
internationally it's in 14 different
languages he's the author of the
complete a to z dictionary of dreams be
your own dream expert and of course his
new book
decode your dreams about unlocking
unconsciousness and learning how it
influences experiences
please welcome to the show ian wallace
direct from scotland
[Music]
ian wallace thank you so much for
joining us on the podcast i got the book
right here i've been devouring it decode
our dreams it's like a it's basically
like a an encyclopedia it's like did you
have a dream about uh i don't know being
pregnant turned to being pregnant on
page you know 71. did you have dreams
about finding money turn to page 115
you'll know what it's about it's a very
useful
book to just kind of keep on your
bedside table
yeah thank you uh yeah it is
a lot of the the work i do with dreams
can be quite academic but i really
always like the idea that dreams should
be something really accessible that
anyone can engage with
so that was one of the reasons behind
writing decode your dreams was the idea
of rather than having some huge tome to
leaf through to understand your dreams
you could just flick flick to that page
and there you go okay but one question
before we get into it because it really
you know i would love to hear we're
gonna have fun with this episode folks
by the way yeah we're gonna talk some
you know metaphysical ideas behind
you're gonna learn a lot about us some
specifics about dreams we're gonna share
some dreams we're gonna bring folks on
with their dreams a good friend of mine
and several uh milkshaker listeners
along the way audience
is demanding answers
so let's just get right to it
why the [ __ ] do we dream i know there's
like 40 different theories about him
none of them sound
we were talking about them earlier in
the show none of them sound
exactly right to me to be honest with
you so in your opinion
why do we dream what's the purpose of
dreams
there are endless theories about
dreaming and because it's such a
powerful experience and because humans
have been dreaming for at least 30 000
years as far as we can make out
then everyone's got an opinion on it
the the opinions really fall into two
camps still
there's the kind of traditional opinion
that dreams are messages from the gods
from beyond
and that's kind of what i call the whole
swirly cape and pointy hat brigade that
dreams are the strange thing and you
better listen to them and you know if
you dream about a horse a week on
thursday your car will break down
and that sort of approach another one's
the academic one that thinks that
dreaming is just some sort of random
electrical activity
and both those approaches take that
outside in approach to try and guess
what's happening inside someone's brain
whereas the approach i take is more of a
an inside out by trying to understand
the imagery that someone generates at
night and sees how that's reflected in
the world around them
so the there's been a lot of
progress probably in the past 20 years
and understanding the dreaming process
and what's revealed is that the
fundamental function of dreaming is it's
a sense-making process
and what's making sense of most of is
our emotions
so when we dream
we we generate images but in waking life
when we
share our emotions when we express
emotions we usually do it in the form of
an image so rain if you were angry with
me you said ian i'm angry with you i
think yeah you may be just a bit
disappointed but if you say ian i'm so
angry i'm going to explode i think well
now i'm dealing with an unexploded bomb
or as if you say you know if you did
that again i will positively erupt so we
use emotions in waking life emotional
imagery
to express our emotions
and we do the same in dreaming so a
dream is not just a stream of emotions
uh not just a stream of imagery it's
also a flow of emotions
so in doing that that's the fundamental
function of dreaming is it's an
emotional processing
okay i got to be honest that's the best
explanation i've ever heard yeah you win
that that was it that was like i was so
ready to poke holes in it
and it's like yeah that that totally
makes sense because and it's so true and
you and you talk about in your dreams in
in the book and in your research about
these emotional components and it's so
true the act of dreaming is just so
emotional um and you know the thing that
uh
you know pisses me off is uh you know
all the
the scientists that kind of dissect
dreams and kind of have these kind of
lame ideas that are obviously just made
up like well dreaming is how we
categorize our memories and sort them
it's like how do you know that
show me the data on that um
but
they are so emo you know all of those
theories don't take in account like how
emotional dreams are we're we're
heartbroken we're unheard we're lonely
we're raging we're we're being attacked
we're fearful uh there's such an
emotional core at the center of dreams
it's pretty rare to have a dream where
you're not feeling isn't that right
i think that that would never happen and
and the other part of it
the reason that dreams have evolved and
we use dreams so much is that
people like researchers like george
lakoff and cognitive scientists at
barclay guys like stanislaus de haan
benjamin levy
uh
they have shown that at least 98 of
human awareness occurs unconsciously
during waking hours
and most of that unconscious awareness
is emotional some of it is spiritual
it's mainly emotional and so the main
way that we process our emotions
is during that
period of sleeping at night when we all
dream for around two hours per night and
we just spend our time generating images
to make sense of our emotion
this podcast is sponsored by better help
hey milkshakers is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
these are hard times this pandemic
we're all being tested to the brink
and um frankly therapy can help and most
therapists
they're booked up months in advance it's
hard to get a new therapist but
betterhelp will assess you and your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating in under 48 hours it
is not a crisis line it's not self-help
it is professional therapy done securely
online there's a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
available locally in many areas and this
service is for clients worldwide so if
you're
listening in from a remote island in the
pacific
better help is your pathway to mental
health and fulfillment and you can log
into your account pretty much any time
and just send a message to your
therapist from that island in the
pacific you'll get timely thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you don't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room like you do with
traditional therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
needed and it's more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and they've
even got financial aid that's available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today so visit their
website read their testimonials they're
posted every day visit betterhelp.com
milkshake that's better help
and join the over 2 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help that they are
recruiting additional therapists in all
50 states reza
special offer for metaphysical milkshake
listeners get 10
off your first month
at betterhelp.com
milkshake thanks better help
folks you know this
ninety percent of the coffee that you
get from a grocery store
is actually stale yeah you heard that
right the coffee you know and think you
love
needs a serious
upgrade so instead of rebuying the same
old same old let trade coffee send you
something freshly roasted that you're
literally guaranteed to love trade sells
the freshest roasted and ethically
sourced beans from america's best
independent roasters they ship free to
you as often as you like whole or ground
so whether you're a coffee nerd or you
just want a better daily cup trades real
coffee experts taste test over 400
roasts and use technology to match you
to your ideal coffee based on your
preferences and brewing method so take
the coffee quiz to get started trade
coffee guarantees you'll love your first
bag or
they'll replace it for free trade has
been featured by the new york times by
wired gq has delivered over five million
bags of coffee their subscription is no
hassle skip shipments change your
frequency or cancel at any time i
actually took the uh the trade coffee
quiz it was so fun you basically just
you know talk about like your
relationship to coffee how do you have
coffee how often do you have it what are
you what are you looking for in a coffee
and then when the the quiz is done
they decide for themselves like what
coffee you're going to love and i got my
very first bag it's called
it's a blue boon coffee which like i
never would have seen this i'm not going
to find this at trader joe's
you guys
and so i've been trying it and it's like
if coffee were made just for me
that's what this coffee would be
and for our listeners right now trade
coffee is offering a total of 20 off
your first three bags when you go to
slash
drinktrade.com
to get started take their quiz at
drinktrade.com slash milkshake and start
your journey to your perfect cup that's
drink trade dot com slash milkshake for
20 off your first three bags
so is this what you mean when you say uh
the dream isn't happening to you you are
happening to the dream
it's it's the yeah absolutely yeah
that's the idea that like the
that every part of the dream every
person in the dream every
aspect of the dream every symbol of the
dream is just basically some reflection
of you
and and
encounter a question to that or in
addition to that and i've heard this
said before from therapists and stuff
that you are you are every character in
the dream in some way shape or form is
that the same thing or is that kind of
different yeah yeah that's absolutely
right so it was discovered in the late
90s by
mark soames who's our south african
neuroscientist that he studied different
parts of the brain in a magnetic
resonance scanner
and the parts that light up
when you dream
are actively creating the dream so there
are parts of it's the ventromesial
forebrain prefrontal cortex
uh the brain stem around the amygdala
and hippocampus so it's all around
creating stories to understand how you
can fulfill emotional needs in waking
life so a dream is fundamentally how you
imagine yourself
or in the modern parlance it's the
ultimate self-portrait the ultimate
selfie so all the characters in the
dream are reflections of usually latent
characteristics that you may have but
you have the opportunity to express and
enact in waking life dreams are the
ultimate selfie i like that
well
that's that's incredible and um
i love what you said about storytelling
and i've never really thought about that
before you know reza and i talk a lot
about storytelling that's something that
we're obviously very involved in we
believe in the power of storytelling we
do that through you know podcasting we
knew that through television we did that
through writing and
but i hadn't really connected dreams as
being kind of the fountain
of storytelling and obviously that's the
foundationally that's what carl jung was
talking about the you know the the
symbols that lie
at the bottom of these dreams are kind
of arc typical
story elements you know mountains and
being crushed and where water comes from
and and darkness and light and these are
having to do with
heroes journey which is our journey
we're all the heroes
in our dreams
exactly right and that's uh
what joseph campbell who originated the
hero's journey when he was doing all the
comparative mythology one of the things
that he said is that a dream is a
private myth and a myth is a public
dream
so there's that idea that much of our
culture and mythology i know that you
are have spent a lot of time exploring
religion
and most of the major religions
especially the either religions come
from a dream that someone a prophet had
a dream some sort of vision and then
from that a religion or spiritual
practices evolved
um well this is really enlightening
because now that i realize that all the
characters uh in my dreams are just me
it just it makes me rethink all the sex
dreams that i have now like i it's
really hard for me to
think about them the same way oh
narcissist look at him
all the sex dreams reza making love to
himself
it's a really fascinating area of sex
dreams i i've just had a an article
published about that
uh and i'm getting a request to talk
more about sex dreams but like
it brings us to a kent house or
dreams quarter well i
i once
had dreams published
yeah so this one was in uh uh in some
newspapers and someone wants to do it in
the new york times now
but work in this area i suppose in the
areas you work in you have
unusual experiences
and i once did an article on sex dreams
for i think it was um cosmopolitan in
brazil
and for the next six months every day
i'd get about 30 or 40
really quite um
lucid descriptions of sex dreams sent to
me which was which was great
it was very good but the mind forward
the thing about
i i've got them in a folder someplace
i'll send them over
um
yeah but the the really interesting
thing there um is that
we always have to understand the
difference between what we create in the
dream and actual reality
and although jung and frey and lots of
other people talk about symbolism people
tend to think of some symbols some kind
of substitute
but what a symbol is is actually a
connection
so it connects something tangible and
real to something intangible allows you
to express the intangible and tangible
form
so when you have a sex dream
you're not really ever dreaming about
some sexual situation or encountering
awaken life
it's what a sex dream means it's what
sex means and sex is all about intimacy
and creativity
so
the psychological word for sex is
procreation
so we have this idea that we have a seed
of an idea and we
have a labor of love we conceive a
project we conceive a plan so all the
language around sex is this idea of
conception of
joining marrying things together
and bring them to fruition and it's
becoming intimately aware of that so
when you create a sex dream there's
something in your awakened life where
you becoming intimately aware that you
have the creative power and creativity
not in the sense that you have to do it
in oils or mixed media or some
site-specific installation but you have
the creative power maybe to solve a
problem
or
create something unique write something
unique perform something unique
so all those sex dreams that you have
are all about using your unique
creativity to bring a labor of love into
fruition
[Music]
oneskin is a longevity company led by a
team of five phds developing solutions
to prevent slow down and reverse aging
one skin harnesses the science of aging
to develop products that extend the
length of time that skin is healthy and
youthful
one skin's topical supplement is a daily
moisturizer powered by their proprietary
peptide os1 the first peptide
scientifically proven to reduce the
biological age of skin
look skin care is healthcare
comprehensive wellness should include
our largest organ skin
one skin's priority is to keep your skin
healthy in order to keep your body
healthy the outstanding beauty benefits
are a consequence of a healthy skin one
skin is for everyone it's designed for
anyone who cares about aging at their
best health and that means men too after
all we should all care about the health
of our largest organ
you keep talking about our largest organ
and i was pretty sure that's not the
skin that is actually the human
liver
but regardless listen one skin is
awesome um i've been using it ever since
they sent me my podcaster free sample
and i'm definitely uh sign me up it's
really amazing i've used a lot of
moisturizers
and it's dry out here in southern
california the water is hard i get out
of the shower my my face feels like
parched
and uh i just i love it it is a a
beautiful facial lubricant and i
literally look 24 years old you look
great
you definitely look great
visit
oneskin.com use code milkshake for 15
off your first purchase the code applies
to one time purchases and the first
order of subscription purchases that's o
n e s k i n dot c o
slash milkshake
and use the code milkshake for 15 off
your first purchase
[Music]
that's amazing now you had mentioned
earlier visions
and i guess there's a lot of other
aspects to dreaming i wanted to get your
opinion on you're a very smart
gentlemanly scott
and um thank you
do you think that visions
happen
do do we have an is a vision is
different than a dream i have a couple
others but let me just start with that
one
yeah so there's um
when you actually examine the dreaming
process and study it
then there's a very very interesting
phase
at the point between waking and dreaming
it's called hypnagogia
and it had been described back in the
19th century but it was brought into
popularity recently
by a separate psychologist andreas
mavromatis
and in hypnagogia
you are in a liminal state
between waking and dreaming
and
your brain is liking the dreaming
process it's actively generating imagery
but you're effectively shining it on to
real world perceptions
so this is what people do in the the
phenomenon of lucid dreaming or in sleep
paralysis
but also can happen
in waking life that idea of a vision
you are taking all the internal imagery
and generating what appears to be
something tangible that's actually
coming in from inside you
so
and it often happens in times of
physical stress
so that's why
native americans
often had that idea of going off into
the wilderness
and finding out what the spirit animal
was by fasting
uh people do it by using drugs you don't
really need to do that
we all do it naturally twice a night
just as you're falling asleep you'll be
thinking about the things that happened
during the day yeah you'd be thinking
about what you're gonna do tomorrow and
you'll have a flash of an image an
uncommanded image that will come into
your mind that's literally the moment
you're falling asleep but you you're in
the hypnagogic phase then and then when
you wake up in the morning which is
usually a bit more leisurely you will be
dreaming and then as you come out of the
dream you'll be aware of your
surroundings in your bedroom but in that
moment you are in a visionary space
again
um that's cool now what about i'm going
to get a little woo-woo here
but what about dreams that tell the
future you know because you do i don't
know that i've had any but i definitely
have had dreams where it kind of turned
into deja vu like i had a dream and then
parts of that dream seemed to just kind
of be coming true in the future but you
must have heard from people like i had a
dream about x y and z and then
sure enough
that came true or it showed me what to
do in the future
um
uh
yeah a lot of people might scoff but i i
think this is a
it's a it's a real thing isn't it have
you encountered this
yeah so there's a there's a phenomenon
called a precognitive dream which is
this idea that you you have a dream and
then whatever happened the events of
that dream then occur in real life
now the challenge with this there are
two approaches to it um
a lot of what we dream uses imagery from
the world around us and a lot of this is
quite mythical or cultural imagery so
for example the 16th most common dream
around the world is an aircraft crash
and thankfully aircraft crashes are very
few and far between
but whenever there is one i get lots of
emails from people saying i dreamt that
airplane was going to crash oh that's
funny and then because it's the 16th
most common dream
and every night planet earth generates
around 35 billion dreams and you think
well there's a fair chance someone's
going to generate the 16th most common
dream
the other side of that though reign is
that people tend to think that dreams
are all about
working through past experiences
but the reality is it's not just going
through past experiences it's also
exploring future expectations
so what we actually do we tend to the
dreams we have are actually projecting
us maybe three or four days into the
future when we're looking at
opportunities
and because we work at that mythical
level in the dream then there are some
things in real life that will match up
with the mythical situations and events
that we're generating the dream
so i often hear it reported that someone
will say i
i dreamt that thing happen
there's a another a very similar
phenomenon where someone will go to a
new city a strange city
and they'll find the streets very
familiar and they'll be walking around
and saying i know this place because i
visit here in my dreams a lot
so it may be something
but it also may just be
a neurological phenomenon and because
the brain's so complex no one has
actually figured it out yet but the key
thing is we always have that mythical
fundamental pattern and we lay our
experience on it so it is possible to
dream of the future
okay so plane crashes top 15 uh
most common dreams we had our our
producer safa
uh write down the top 10
most
common dreams and we don't need to go
through all of them but we thought we'd
you know mention a few of them and then
you give us your okay sort of id you
know idea what it is why why do we have
these dreams all the time so
uh
this one this one is very very common
i've had this a lot of people have had
this it's the whole teeth falling out
dream
right i think at one point or another
everyone has had
the teeth falling out dream what what is
that what is that about
this is the second most common dream
around the world
and again people have all sorts of old
wife stills about it it thinks about um
they're right about getting old or
worried about losing money
in some cultures it means that a
relative is about to pass away i thought
freud said something about masturbation
am i am i wrong about that
then again i think wasn't that his
that was his answer to every dream right
well he said lots of things about
masturbation we'll come back to teeth in
a minute but freud was really
interesting because
um if you actually look at all the terms
he uses around dreaming there's things
like resolute residue distillation
transference
sublimation he took all his terms to
describe dreams from 19th century
industrial chemistry
and so that's why he was an analyst he
was like a chemical analyst of dreams
and that's kind of where
a lot of working with dreams went a bit
awry
because right about that time
the word psyche or psychology shifted
from being the study of the soul and
spirit to being the study of the mind
and the soul and spirit where all the
emotions are so people concentrate on
thoughts in the mind
and that was largely down to segment
well fun fun fact
fun fact sigmund freud used to
masturbate into a sock full of teeth
so well that explains everything now
now i get it yeah anyways but you didn't
you didn't so what's your name
teeth falling out teeth falling out yeah
so the way uh that i work with dreams
the way the modern way is to work with
the imagery and and what it means so we
tend to show our teeth on two main
occasions one is when we're happy and
smiling we're feeling confident and the
other one is when we're kind of snarling
we're searching ourselves we're baring
our teeth exactly
uh when we're showing our power so teeth
symbolize power and confidence this is
why people tend to wear sharp teeth on
necklaces we have all these idioms and
linguistics around it so you're getting
your teeth into something uh the french
say that if you are ambitious uh if it's
obviously done long you've got big teeth
right if you're hugely ambitious
your teeth are so big they're scraping
the floor so teeth are all about power
and confidence if you dream your teeth
are falling out and usually the idea uh
the vision the dream is that your teeth
are crumbling that suggests that your
feelings of confidence are crumbling and
waking life so the action from the
dreams going because the dream system
just till you put it into action is to
show up and appear more confident and
step into your power
okay
my question is about two in a row and
this is numbers most popular dreams
number common dreams number six and
number seven and that is flying and
falling i've had a lot of flying dreams
when i was young i used to be tormented
by falling dreams i had so many
falling dreams like oh and i can't catch
myself and i'm just and as i hit i wake
up and then there was kind of a a myth
in my junior high school i don't know
why
in seattle in the 70s i guess i know
what you're going to say because it was
in my high school too go yeah oh okay it
was yeah that if you
actually in your dream
hit the ground without waking you will
die die i i heard that too it's like
it is like it's like the same thing
about you know don't say bloody mary
three times uh
into a mirror candy man candy
candy man yeah so so with that one
falling flying so that the the following
and dying one i always think well how
would you know that someone was having a
falling dream if they
expired all those people who died in
their sleep we now we now know why yeah
exactly yeah so the um so flying is the
sixth most common dream and it is very
common amongst creative people
and again working with language we have
the idea that weight is associated with
responsibility
i've got a big weight on my shoulders
don't you realize the gravity of the
situation
uh
this task is proving to be a real burden
that's really weighing me down
so when you feel you are released from
some practical considerations or you can
rise above a situation by using your
creativity
then you have that flying dream you feel
that you're walking on air and and
you're rising above it all and people
have the flying dream in all sorts of
different ways flying like superman and
flying an aircraft or in a spaceship all
sorts of ways it's about that idea of
liberating your creativity
and rising above any earthly burdens you
have
the other side of the corollary of
falling there are two aspects to this
there's a physical aspect and there's a
psychological aspect the physical one is
when you go to sleep all your large
antigravity muscles start to relax
and just at the moment where everything
is getting relaxed you often experience
a thing called a myclonic jerk or a
micronic twitch because that kind of
like that and you feel like you've just
fallen off a
or falling down the stairs or something
yeah and you sometimes wake yourself up
and that is literally the moment you are
falling asleep
the other one in the psychological
aspect the dreaming one of falling
falling is really associated with
failure that you
are concerned that you're going to fail
at something and you're hanging on
really really tightly
and it suggests that in waking life
you're trying to micromanage something
you're trying to over control it and
you're hanging on really really tightly
to an outcome rather than the process of
getting to the outcome so the action
from that dream from the following dream
the seventh most common one is
just to relax your grip a little
and influence things and steer things
but just relax your grip and let things
fall into place
we keep talking about top 10 dreams uh
just so our
listeners know what they are uh top 10
dreams in order top 10 most common
dreams being chased is number one number
two teeth falling out we talked about it
number three unable to find a toilet
we've all had that usually ends with a
wet bed
number uh
that was number three number four naked
in public it's a common one number five
uh like unprepared for an exam
i had that all the time but i had like
the phd version of that which is like i
didn't do the right margins
in my dissertation
and no one bothered to tell me you know
um yeah flying double spacing yeah
double spacing
uh falling number seven we did that one
number eight okay this one is me
the out of control vehicle right the out
of control vehicle
eighth most common
dream
i have this one all the time but it's so
real like
for me it usually involves like the
brakes
aren't working in the car and i am
pushing the brake it's not that they're
not working they're just like
they they respond to how hard i push
them and so i am pushing
this [ __ ] brake
with all of my might and it's sort of
slowing me down and then i wake up and
i've got a cramp all the way up my leg
that's a very common one the out of
control
vehicle
um what is that one what does that one
mean
anytime we dream about a vehicle when we
create that dream then we are
considering how we are making progress
towards a particular objective or
outcome in waking life
the type of vehicle uh will reflect
what you're involved in uh the car or
the automobile is the most common one
because it's a personal vehicle but
people dream about buses and trains and
submarines and aircraft carriers and all
sorts of things
but when you're in a car or an
automobile
uh and you feel it's out of control
there's some situation in your waking
life and again working with a language
where you are trying to drive forward
with something you're using your
ambition and drive to arrive at an
outcome
and
often when you dream that you and the
break is ineffective you can feel over
committed to something
that you
really want to get to an outcome
there's a huge amount of work to do to
and you're not getting enough time to
slow down and reflect on what's
happening consider it so it can be it
often happens if you're trying to work
to a particular deadline
that you're trying to reach a certain
destination by a certain time that's
mine i just want to slow
the action from that dream is that you
have another control in the car apart
from the brake which is the steering
wheel and you can just steer yourself
gently
and steer around there might be
shortcuts to it there might be other
things you can do
but rather than getting that cramp in
your leg just have a look in the rear
view mirror and have a bit of a
reflection or where you've been and how
that's working for you i'm gonna i'm
gonna remember that next time just to
round up the top ten here number nine
after uh number eight is out of control
vehicle number nine
finding an unused room which i actually
i think i've had this stream once before
like when you're in your house and
suddenly you notice a door you've never
noticed before and you open the door and
you're like what the f where did this
room come from that's a that's a the
ninth most common one and the tenth most
common
dream
being late
right you're late to something hmm i
guess you know russia and i were talking
earlier ian um
and you know when you go through so many
of these there's so many there's so much
anxiety right being chased
yeah just a friend can't find a toilet
you're naked and you're embarrassed i
get a lot of laced cars out of control
yeah cars out of control falling
you know being late so this
you know that just that that anxiety
like so two-part question what does this
say about us as a society as a
civilization
and the second part is
have they done dream studies of like the
kalahari bushmen or the pygmies in the
jungle do they have i'm sure they don't
have out of are they worried about the
exam
but yeah are they worried about being
naked in public if they're naked in
public most of the day
uh yes very true well the uh
yeah so the
uh the first i'll come back i was just
about to launch into the second part
because there's some really interesting
anthropological information there but in
the in the first part uh what it says
about us as a culture is a lot of what
happens in our culture is idealized uh
particularly through social media if you
look through someone's insta feed
there's often lots and lots of
idealizations of the person they'd like
to be
so we have these very
high
expectations these platonic idealisms of
who we should be
but not the reality of who we are so we
always have that that gap between there
and
uh irving goffman the sociologist wrote
a lot about this in his 1956 book the
presentation of self in everyday life
about how we present ourselves often as
theater in every life or guided board
wrote about it in the spectacle the
society of the spectacle
so these things that happen are often
because we are trying to live up to
an impossible or ideal of who we think
we should be
rather than actually engaging with who
we really are
who we've been and most importantly who
we can become
so that's why we often get anxious
because
of that distance that apparent distance
between who we actually are and who we
think we should be in the eyes of other
people
and in terms of
different tribes different cultures
different credos having different dreams
they they really all have similar types
of dreams so they i wrote a book about
10 years ago called the top 100 dreams
which was just based on studies of
dreams from people all around the world
so
someone in the kalahari
they will dream about being chased
and
the reason for that is another word for
chase is a pursuit
so they might not be pursuing a
some
award they might not be pursuing some
big job
but they will be pursuing a particular
outcome
and so that idea of pursuit is not just
something chasing you you're actually
chasing something
being naked in public
that idea is it's all around the actual
clothing you present so with the clothes
we wear as i'm dressed as a sober
psychologist this evening but the
clothes we wear are the images we like
to present and then if i was showing up
in different clothes
then i'd be presenting a different
self-image and in terms of being exams
and you know there might be some
amazonian tribe that aren't studying for
phds and doing margins and double
spacing but they will have initiation
rights they will have tests of manhood
and womanhood that they have to pass in
order to be accepted into the tribe as
adults so we have all these things and
all of human culture and human behavior
and they're reflected in how we process
our emotions in our dreams
all right
here comes the fun part
let's
let's psychoanalyze uh
our guests uh that will be calling in
and then of all also the and our hosts
of this podcast i'll start i've shared
this stream with
rain before this is a dream that i have
had
all my life
it's a recurring dream it i have it
i don't know
maybe
i'm gonna say maybe four or five times a
year
and it's a
it's a derivative of the teeth falling
out dream but it's not the teeth falling
out dream usually the way the dream
works is
it it often begins with me chewing gum
so i'm chewing gum or something
and then the gum gets stuck in my molars
like it gets stuck in my molars and so i
reach into my mouth and i
pulled the gum
but the gum has like this infinite
stretch ability and i'm just pulling and
i'm pulling and the more i pull the more
the molar it the molar never comes out
but it just it yanks and i could feel it
in my jaw it's the most
real sensation it's just yanking it and
yanking it and then
so at some point what happens is that
the gum stops being gum or usually like
it a bit of it comes out but there's
still i can feel with my tongue there's
still a little bit there like underneath
the
the tooth and then i will reach in there
and i'll grab it and it's not so much
gum as it is just kind of like a
like a a fibrous material almost like um
almost like uh
like a tendon or something that i just
pull and i pull a little bit more and i
think i'll just pull just a little bit
more and it'll come out i can feel it
sort of
coming out of my gums
again the sensation is so real
uh even now as i'm talking about it i
can absolutely feel it and i just keep
going and going and i think if i just go
a little bit more i'll i'll cut it off
at the end i could like bite it off but
then there's a little piece still
missing there's a little piece still
sticking out so i so i keep pulling at
it i keep pulling at it
it is maddening and it never
ever ends
what the hell is happening to me ian
what's happening to me yeah
this is the 54th most common dream from
around the world get out of here
no it's uh it's absolutely it's a as you
were saying that they weren't jerking
yeah it's the is the 54th most common
one uh it can be chewing gum some people
have trico it's interesting what happens
is
some people just stay with chewing gum
uh people i often talk about some sort
of thread of some fibrous material
that's it which is what you share
so again um the the mouth is how we
communicate it's how we share our
feelings how we share our emotions and
how we express our needs
and because it's linked to the throat
all the stuff's kind of come out of your
mouth and throat
the neck is what connects your heart and
head your thoughts and emotions
so there is something in waking life
where you feel you need to
say something
you need to get something out of your
mouth and it's usually some sort of
story some sort of narrative and that's
why it comes out in that string all the
time
but um it's messy uh and it's sticky and
you feel that if you say
what you need to say
then it will be maybe upsetting for
other people to be messy for them and
you maybe get stuck in a situation so it
suggests in waking life that you are
maybe
very polite
uh you maybe don't say
what you'd really like to say sometimes
to other people
and you're always trying to keep the
peace and be very nice but sometimes um
you really need to
chew things over
because this is what this is all about
you need to chew things over and
understand what you really want to say
to people and because it's like chewing
gum one of the things that happens with
chewing gum is very often it's sugar
coated
so in waking life you might sugar coat
what you say to other people
using lots of euphemisms and platitudes
rather than just coming out and just
saying straight what you need from them
and it's not being demanding it's not
being unpleasant it's just being very
honest and doing that or whatever
that's what we call it
yeah maybe it's a terror holy [ __ ] i
mean like you you've you have glanced
into my soul because
this is actually a problem that i that i
talk to my counselor a lot about which
is i don't share my thoughts or my
counselor your school counselor my own
counselor you go after class to your
school counselor and talk to you yes uh
she she's she expects great things from
me
um
no but in all honesty this whole thing
that like i i i do not share my thoughts
and emotions because often times i just
feel like uh it's just gonna open up a
can of worms is it even
like i'll just keep it to myself like
why why should i
you know say this i'll just i'll just
keep it to myself it's too sticky you
know it's too messy
uh and uh and i don't i don't say it
that's a holy [ __ ] man people
let's do more of these
rain
that's fantastic okay so here's mine
boom i'm mixing it up let's get crazy
i'm not gonna share a dream in because
honestly i can't really remember any
juicy ones but drugs just this morning
my dear friend yasi texted me and she
said i had a horrible nightmare about
you
and she texted me like a three-page text
where she had dreamed about me and i was
like hey are you free at 5 p.m
can you come on our show so i'm bringing
my friend yasi on the show and she's
going to share
her dream
all right
come on down um hey everybody please
welcome to the show uh my good friend
yasi
hi yasi
hi rain
and yasi is a sometimes sometimes
frequent
and infrequent listener of metaphysical
milkshake is that not correct
it's true i've actually listened to
every episode i know the last guy i
think that was on here claimed that but
i actually have wow
and listen to every episode that's
amazing thank you so much for your
support and yasi is a as an
up-and-coming singer-songwriter now in
the portland oregon area and um
and oddly enough as we were getting
ready to record this
uh you texted me this morning with a
kind of a nightmare about me in which i
am a raging [ __ ] we have one of the
world's greatest dream authorities in uh
ian wallace he's also a pilot session
musician and a fashion photographer so
he can jam with you on your album and
shoot your album cover
and fly you to your gigs but and once
you make it big he can counsel you
yes and he's also a therapist so um it's
kind of all in one fact i think you guys
should consider getting married but
more than that
tell us please fill us into the dream
spare no detail but don't take too too
long okay go okay all right i'll do my
best okay so the dream starts in what is
presumed presumably rain's home except
it doesn't look like rain's home it's a
big
room uh inside a series of rooms with a
bunch of windows that outlook onto the
rest of this house presumably
and it starts with me opening the shades
to these windows and i'm in this large
space
and it's clear in the dream that
some impending doom is going to happen
there's some attack that's going to be
happening on the property and um
people random people are coming into
this this this place not the room but
the broader house uh trying to seek
shelter and fortification in this place
and so
it's understood that that that that is
that's
the the setting and the and and the
situation and so i find myself uh moving
about the house
uh exiting and spending most of the
dream outside of this structure trying
to set up fortifications and running
into various characters like rain sun
makes an appearance at one point as i'm
opening the shades
and there's no real dialogue other than
just you know
moving about and doing our business
because we understand that um it's
almost like a zombie invasion or
something like that yeah kind of like
except it's unclear you know it's it
seems like there's like a level of
aspect of persecution happening but un
unclear if it's sentient or not so it's
just this doom
um and it's understood that when the
when night falls that uh the attack the
attacks will begin yeah
so
so we're working we're working and i run
around and you know i never actually see
rain except from a distance um
but it's understood that i'm there and
my purpose is to you know fortify this
place there's no way getting out you
know people are running this kind of a
rohan defend rohan kind of moment
and gondor is not coming you know uh so
so so you know time moves by and there's
a there's a woman who i don't know who's
present um
kind of assisting me with the with the
fortifications
and it comes to be the sun is setting on
the on the horizon
there's a forest i notice behind this
this big property and
um
and i ask this person if they've seen
rain
and there's also an awareness that my
brother and his family are present at
the house and none of these people have
ever met so it's very strange to me
um but they're all there and i asked the
woman and she says oh you didn't know
they left about three hours ago they
they abandoned the the property
and so i was frantic running here here
and there trying to trying to understand
like how could this possibly happen in
the dream um and as the sun was setting
i i ran from the front fortification
which was just this sort of chain link
wall something like you might imagine
and walking dead to the back of
furthermost back of the property and
called rain on the phone and was like
what is happening where are you
and uh rain very calmly
uh let me know
that uh that about midday they decided
that they were gonna sneak away
and leave
and they figured that i was too
committed to the cause of trying to hold
this place and that if i
if they if they took me with them
that
that i'd give them up to the rest of the
people and there would be some disorder
and so they decided in an effort to save
themselves that they would leave me
behind and them is rain his family my
brother his family and so i'm with this
you know i'm in this this space now and
as soon as that that realization hits
the first attacks start on the front of
this combo you were abandoned by two
families right before the attack
happened right before the attack and so
yeah so the dream kind of ends i start
weeping on the phone and he's still on
the phone it's very strange so we're
still on the phone and my my initial
thoughts and the dream were like what
did i do
like what did i it wasn't anger it was
like what did i what did i do like how
could i be fooled or cheated in this way
now ian and before we go i want to hear
your analysis do you want some
background information on me and yasi's
relationship
uh
no yeah well
affected
so usually when i i work with clients
then i i get a lot of backstory and
stuff from them but let's just go
straight into this okay uh and just see
what happens with it
so you'll see um
not thinking of dream rain but rain in
real life what is the one quality that
you associate with him
one quality uh what do i associate with
rain
oh man
my friend
he's a friend a really a true friend to
me
yeah
okay
anytime we dream about our house so we
said that being chased is the number one
dream theme the number one dream symbol
is the house
and the reason for that is the house
symbolizes the self houses have got
insides and outsides and so do we
and all the rooms in the house represent
different aspects of our character so
that's why the the ninth dream my most
common dream finding an unused room is
all around our area
so you'll see when you are in this house
that you're trying to
fortify
then there's something in waking life
where you are um protecting yourself in
some way and it's not like you are
shying away from something it's you
making yourself
stronger and more powerful maybe
uh feeling a bit less vulnerable around
something
so there's a whole series of rooms in
there so all those rooms are different
aspects of your character and probably
aspects of your creativity particularly
because you're going around opening up
these windows
a window is how we
perceive a particular situation it's how
we form our perspective on it when
there's our viewpoint it's something
that we look through to understand and
make sense of a situation
so something in your waking life where
you've got lots and lots of different
aspects to your character
and lots of different aspects to your
creativity
and you're forming
opinions and perspectives
on how you can position yourself
in waking life and present yourself to
the world around you
when you feel that there's an attack on
the property
it's not that someone's attacking you in
waking life it's not like there's some
music critic that's saying oh i don't
know about that what you're actually
doing is you are maybe attacking
yourself a bit
that you're being
quite self-critical
about yourself about the image you're
presenting or what you're sharing with
the world
you're maybe being a bit judgmental
you're maybe being a bit too analytical
so that's why you are you're moving
around the house is you're trying to be
kind of a moving target to yourself that
when you criticize one aspect of
yourself then you move to another area
where you maybe feel a bit more
comfortable with yourself
so you're trying to
create this um feeling where you feel
more powerful and less vulnerable to the
opinions of others but particularly to
the critical opinions of yourself
and this feeling of the sun setting
it's not like the ending of something
it can be the end of maybe a
professional cycle but it's usually this
idea of going into the night of going
into that darkness because that's where
all the good stuff is that's where all
creativity comes from is from the
darkness and artists like you going in
there and illuminating that darkness and
bringing treasure back out
uh the woman uh women and
there's all sorts of
ways of exploring the gender spectrum
but women traditionally in a dream
represents your creativity your
intuition your empathy your sensitivity
your ability to nurture something
and a forest symbolizes
an area of
potential natural growth that is unknown
and unfamiliar to you oh my gosh you've
got this area
it's just crazy
so in in doing that this idea of three
hours ago
then numbers and dreams uh you can take
a numerological approach which works up
to a point but that number three will
have some significance so it can be
something uh in the dream uh it might be
three months ago it might be three years
ago maybe three weeks ago
it's probably not just three hours ago
and it can also be to do with maybe
three things but usually there's
something there's some time period for
you are giving yourself a hard time
about
and
before you feel let down
uh
the quality that you feel that you are
letting yourself down the quality that
you feel you're abandoning yourself is
your ability to be friendly to yourself
to give yourself affection and
unconditional love and unconditional
care
so the whole dream is about you
understanding the huge creative
potential that you have with all these
rooms and forming all these perspectives
but you feel that one part of you
is constantly attacking that creative
part
because
sometimes you feel you're not worth it
but the action from the dream you say is
you need to feel that affection for
yourself you need to nurture yourself
and you need to spend some time
making sure that you know that you're
loved
wow
that's profound
y'all see that's
that's not resonant at all is it
no no not at all so background yassie's
getting ready
literally ready in the next couple
months to start recording her first
album
and is right also having to raise a lot
of money to do it she doesn't have like
a trust fund or something like that so
she's having to do like a go fund me and
get the support of her friends and
people from her faith community and and
whatnot and musical supporters of her
and so it's kind of scary it's asking
for money and then putting that money on
the line and hiring someone that charges
thousands of dollars a day and
having to come up plus creatively
come up with these songs and stuff and i
have been a great supporter of hers
of like
you know hey time to record your album i
introduced her to a bunch of producers
in the portland area that i knew through
the grapevine
um and
have been like hey make sure you're
writing your songs you can do it this is
gonna be great i'm a huge supporter of
her artistic
uh expression
um but it's interesting that i'm i've
absented myself in some way from this
dream ian what do you think
yeah that that does make sense it
continues to
to build upon that understanding
and it is that part is when you go into
any new venture
and again the house symbol is is really
interesting because when you have all
those rooms in the house again it's like
that ninth most common dream
it's all about your potential it's all
about you know exactly what you have
done rain you have been opening doors
for yourself
and those doors that you open lead into
all these different rooms and you have
been
opening up
josh's perspective you have been
showing her a window of opportunity to
do that and to move into something else
so all those parts of it and it is
really um
challenging
and i i can empathize with you you see
because i uh
quite a lot of the work i'm doing just
now
is around developing artificial
intelligence
i myself and my business partner have
had to go out and raise money
and uh
put our money on the line and do all
those things
and it can be really quite terrifying if
you think what if it doesn't work what
if it doesn't work
but you know it will
because that's why you're doing it
there's that part of you that keeps
driving forward and it's something that
you need to do
and in doing that you need to realize
that the people will support you
but it can be very hard to ask for
support particularly if you're quite
self-contained
it can be because you can seem really
needy
and feel of no worth and feel like yeah
and then you've just got to get beyond
that and just step into your power
and show up as a powerful person
and claim your value
y'all see how does that resonate
it resonates it was terrifying i woke up
crying from the dream because i ran to
the forest and was cowering
you know
on the phone waking up from the dream
and i was like what the hell is this
yeah so i touched and you know
yeah the phones were interesting as well
there's um phones figure often in dreams
and that's all about getting your
message across so you're trying to get
your message across not just to rain
but and not just your creative message
your musical message but you're also
trying to get the message across to
friends
to actually
state your needs it seems like this
dream was just a perfect encapsulation
with all of these rich union
metaphors and symbols that kind of sums
up exactly where yasi is and what she's
going through it's incredible the house
the windows the woman next to her the
phone the forest the night time um i
mean it's just it's so clear that her
subconscious is
really
churning and kind of supporting her uh
on this journey right
yeah a dream is how you imagine yourself
and
dreams are just all images they're all
these emotional images and your
imagination is just all emotional images
so we do this every night the dream is
how we imagine who we are
well thank you so much yasi i hope you
got something out of this thanks for
coming on this show
thank you jose a lot to digest
and uh always
please uh if you have any further
thoughts you'll see send them to me and
i'll forward them to
to ian ian i feel like you should be
knighted you should be siri and wallace
i don't know why
sir ian can we do a couple more
yeah absolutely thanks joss
thank you take care y'all
all right so uh we thought it would be
fun uh now that we heard from yosi that
we could invite um
you know our staff our producers our
engineers uh uh a metaphysical milkshake
uh all of them are very very disturbed
individuals uh and so they i'm sure have
some
really [ __ ] up dreams and they frankly
need all the help they can get so let's
start with one of our engineers the
great libor yanasik
hey libor thank
welcome to the show we never get to hear
from old libor
of our sessions behind the scenes there
would be no metaphysical milkshake
without libor
i'm excited to be on mine is not really
a dream i drink so i don't dream because
when i don't drink i have the wildest
craziest dreams
the main dream that i have is i'm being
chased and i can't remember if i flat my
arms i could fly away and free myself
so i literally i i mean my mind is so
full of different things that's going on
in
being in the creative atmosphere so
i
drink so i don't dream so i can get a
good night's rest
the combo the combo of uh
top 10
dreams number one being chased and
number six flying it's a combo of the
two
but he forgets that he can fly
i don't think this is a dream analysis i
think this is a uh
logical analysis i think it's important
alcoholism actually
so your family your family is here
thank you yeah yeah it's just an
intervention are we doing an
intervention
yeah so uh so it's very interesting that
you say that you drink uh not to dream
labor everyone dreams so on average so
humans sleep in 90 minute cycles they'll
trade in rhythm
and in each one of those we will have a
dream episode so if you sleep for seven
or eight hours per night
you will have
five sleep cycles and five dream
episodes at the start of the night
they're quite short maybe 10 or 15
minutes by morning you're up to 40 or 45
minutes so you spend about two hours per
night dreaming everyone does we spend
the twelfth of our life streaming
one thing that alcohol does
is
it
reduces your ability to
remember your dreams
so it does suppress dreaming activity it
suppresses rim activity up to a point
and one of the things you'll notice is
that when you stop drinking or you don't
drink for a few nights you'll experience
something called rem rebound
where you're you start to catch up on
all your dreaming
the same thing happens with people who
experience sleep deprivation
that if someone doesn't sleep for 40
hours
when they go to sleep just about all
their sleep is dreaming because dreaming
is the most important part of sleep so
you're catching up on all your sleep
so being chased is the most common dream
flying is the sixth most common dream so
being chased we have this word pursuit
in our language pursuit is being chased
or chasing something
so there's some ambition that you're
pursuing in waking life labor something
that you're trying to achieve and if you
are a busy man with lots and lots of
tasks trying to do that you'll feel that
you're always under pressure
no one's chasing you you're chasing
yourself to perform as best as you can
in pursuit of excellence
and then when you start flapping your
arms your arm is how you shape and you
control your life so when you take
control of a situation and start to
shape it into the form that you want it
to be for the outcome that's when you
rise above it that's when you feel that
weight come off your shoulders
that's when you release yourself from a
burden and you start flying so that's
the process that happens in your dream
how's that sound there libor
it sounds great it's just like jumping
out of a perfectly good place like
playing when i skydive
also
you have
you have friends and people who love you
so thank you you know i appreciate that
appreciate your support
well thank you for the time it was
amazing to learn about my uh drinking
and uh not dreaming and now i totally
understand it maybe i should go back on
the drinking
yeah go back get it my advice would be
my advice would be stick with the
dreaming it's much healthier and far
more powerful things for sure
dreaming is health is healthier than
drinking yourself blotto every night
till you pass out
well
yeah it's uh it's an unusual concept but
it is
even come in this is coming from a
scotsman libor
i know yeah i'm a check yeah i was born
in czech republic
it's very similar drinking cultures yeah
yes
all right next up we have uh our
producer dj lubell who we make fun of a
lot uh he for some reason pronounces his
last name lubel which don't do that
don't don't don't call him lubel
it's like a it's lubell all right it's a
proud family name
is like a kind of sex toy right am i
wrong about that
rain why is someone named reza aslan
making fun of my name i just
helped me dj dj lubell
uh are intrepid intrepid uh producer
uh on the pod uh welcome welcome uh uh
introduce yourself to mr wallace and and
let's hear your intimate intimate dreams
well first of all dr wallace it's an
honor and a privilege i um as a producer
of metaphysical i've been researching
you for the last week so the fact that i
get to have a conversation with you
i'm very blessed is what i'm trying to
say um so i actually had a dream this
morning and it's been with me all day
it's uh it was odd it's i feel like it's
it's rather unusual but
so i
was transported to 1988
and i was walking around the set of
naked gun
um
i love that movie it's a great it's a
fantastic movie classic and like leslie
nielsen who's one of my favorite actors
of all time
was just sort of like showing me around
and he's like and it felt so vivid and i
felt like i was seeing this movie
in a way that i've never seen this film
before because he's showing me like all
the characters and the actors that
played the characters and like he
introduced me to the prop master which
which is strange in itself and i don't
know it was just really sweet having
this moment with this person who passed
away a few years ago and obviously meant
so much to me and my family and you know
people who love comedy in general
and uh and then i woke up and i felt sad
that i was no longer with leslie nielsen
now just to be clear no connection yes
in the real world to leslie nielsen
you've never met him
never now
now this might sound weird but you were
dreaming about the naked gun did you
have an erection while having this dream
i think that explains i always
i always have an erection when i sleep
dr wallace help me no i don't know if i
had an erection
yeah so that that would be the freudian
interpretation rain
when
we dream about celebrities
then we are dreaming about
qualities and powers that we have
potential powers and qualities that we
need to celebrate so the celebrity dream
is the 26th most common dream and we use
celebrities
uh as a way of symbolizing
agency uh having power having resources
and the ability to make choices about
what we do with those resources
we also use them as a way of symbolizing
admiration and respect so when you go
back to
1988 dj
there's
an idea of something that's in your past
and it might not be in 1988
it might be something a bit more recent
probably
but you are transporting yourself into a
situation
where
you can actually acknowledge
even though
the guys around you might seem to be
giving you a hard time
you can actually acknowledge that you
are admired and respected
for your skills and your capabilities
and the idea of the naked gun
it's a really interesting film or the
series because
um
it has quite a serious plotline but the
whole thing
is really entertaining and it's kind of
what you like what you do with the
metaphysical milkshake
it is quite a profound storyline but
there's a lot of entertainment around
that and the fact that you're getting
shown around it or what you're actually
doing the dream is showing yourself that
you understand all the intricacies of
making this happen of making this event
happen of creating things so things like
speaking to the props master you even
know what to do you know with the best
boys you know where the gaffer is you
know how to where all the lighting
panels are you know where the spare
fuses are
all these things that you need to know
to technically create
something that is shared across the
world
you are realizing that you maybe don't
need to look to other people for respect
and admiration for that you just need to
acknowledge yourself you need to
celebrate the fact that you're doing
something that is universally respected
and admired
no matter what the other guys are saying
about you
will i ever get the respect of rayne
wilson
just out of curiosity
well that remains to be seen yeah i'm
not gonna i wouldn't hold your breath on
that one you know this this analysis
actually rings really true to me because
the one thing that rain and i know about
dj that you don't know ian is that dj
thinks he's funny
and
she's not
and
it makes sense though it makes i mean a
lot of what you said made sense
in light of that
important information all right i have i
hope you have more dreams about the
naked gun
it's not like that thank you dj thanks
for coming on the show thank you for
thank you for being on the show dj
great thank you guys okay one last one
we have another one of our producers uh
safa samosai
yeah
we have another uh producer on the show
uh that we're going to invite safa
samazadeh jazz uh
she
her dream is a little dark which i think
is appropriate because
as
we have talked about you know
the vast majority of our dreams are
negative
and uh and so uh we thought we would end
on on a little bit of a serious note uh
safa how's it going
it's going great so um
a little bit of backstory here
um i was a freshman in high school in
littleton colorado uh when columbine
happened
i know people who made out of it alive
and i had a friend who did not
i was five miles away when it happened i
i went to a sister school
it was it was about as close as you
could get to experiencing it without
physically being there the connections
between the schools
um a year later i was in a bad car
accident i had brain damage and as a
result my hand was permanently paralyzed
in that year between the two events i
started having a lot of dreams about car
accidents
i always attribute to okay this is me
processing columbine um
and but as time as time went on what's
interesting i don't believe in
premonitions um but as time went on the
dream started becoming more and more
about my hand and the last one i
remember having
um
there was the mother of a of someone i
knew i columbine who had brain damage as
well when he was shot in the head and i
remember her in the dream saying it's a
shame what happened to her hand
after that i don't remember having any
more because that's where my memory kind
of starts to cut off from the head
injury but yeah that's always been a
weird
again i don't believe in premin but yeah
between those two events these
weird dreams about something that ended
up happening
yes after thanks for sharing that that
is that's really touching
there's um we were talking earlier about
pre-cognitive dreams and and
premonitions
and we do live on these two levels we
live in
a scientific world but also a mythic
world
and very often in that then we
take the meanings of things we take the
symbolic significance of things so so if
you hadn't shared your backstory with me
you said that you were dreaming about a
car accident in which your hand was
injured
the
symbolic interpretation of that is so
it's like the out of control vehicle
dream that we were speaking about
earlier
when you dream that you're in a car
wreck or a car accident a car crash
then there is something
in your waking life where you are
concerned that your driving ambition is
kind of getting out of control a bit or
there is something that you're trying to
come to terms with maybe like the the
columbine tragedy that you're trying to
come to terms with and it just seems
such a mess
and what your hand does your hand
shapes and controls your life shapes and
controls your future
so the symbolic interpretation would be
something in waking life that you're
really concerned is getting out of
control
and it will affect your ability to shape
your future
which may be because of some traumatic
incident
but the fact that it then happened in
reality now there are two ways to
explain that one is it's just
a tragic coincidence
and the other one is there is a more
symbolic synchronistic connection
uh that there is no current
psychological
or neurological explanation for
and
in the the work that i do i've been
doing this for a while now
and i've worked with over 400 000 dreams
for my clients
and there are a few dreams like your one
where something is really clear like
that
and it is
that's one of the mysteries of dreaming
that
you can engage with it and accept at a
certain level
a symbolic level
but there's always that feeling that
because the dream is getting more
intense and more intense and more
focused and more detailed
then what led up to that and there may
have been something in your environment
that maybe before then you had
some
near misses when you were in a vehicle
and you were worried about that or you
may
the hand that you lost the use of
sapphire was it your was it your
dominant hand yes
yeah
yeah so you may have been concerned that
you have the ability to shape and
control and do something with
but uh yeah thank you for sharing that
it's something that is uh beyond current
psychological understanding
exactly how that happens and all we can
say is
uh there's the thought of something the
reality of it
but often more importantly there's the
why of it that symbolic mythic
unconscious significance of it
thank you safa thank you so much that is
a very um
touching moving
challenging dream and uh
hope ian was able to shed some light on
it and just thank you so much for
for sharing it and
just know from our end we so appreciate
all the work you do on metaphysical
milkshake and all the beautiful research
and the questions you come up with
and guests that you find
you're so much better than dj thank you
so far why would you why would you say
that
uh ian wallace this has been
definitely one of my favorite episodes
uh of this podcast thank you so much for
all the time and the attention
uh we know that you're you're calling
from scotland it's like two in the
morning over there and you've been so
patient with us we could we could talk
about our dreams all day this must be
what your life is like i mean you're
you're that guy on the airplane where
like you sit next to and you're like hey
what do you do oh i analyze dreams oh
this is gonna be a long flight
but we really appreciate it
yeah no i've hugely enjoyed uh just
meeting you guys and i
just it's been really great that you've
shared your dreams and the word dream
has two meanings in our language it
means these nightly phenomena that we
all create but it's also our hopes and
ambitions and aspirations in waking life
and it's just really great to
um have those shared and understand more
about what you do
uh
listeners if you guys had fun with this
episode like we did definitely get your
hands on decode your dreams uh it's just
like this encyclopedic book about what
every dream you've ever had possibly
means
thank you again uh ian wallace thanks
ian this has been such a pleasure
thank you really enjoyed it
[Music]
folks if you want more of life's big
questions you can find us on social at
reza aslan and at rainwilson and on
twitter at metamilkpodcast and instagram
at metaphysical milkshake let us know
your life's big questions your dreams
who knows we might just explore them on
a future episode
and remember to follow rate and review
metaphysical milkshake on apple podcasts
and wherever else you listen to your
podcasts and
if you like watching us talk subscribe
to our youtube channel and watch full
episodes every week
thanks so much
sweet dreams reza
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubel
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
what exactly are the high stakes when it
comes to celebrity psychology
curious
you were talking about yes you know
these high stakes industries like making
sure that
rain feels okay about not having won
that emmy
i don't have as many instagram followers
as john krasinski
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you